pourquoi adhérer au Républicain parce
que
vous savez
si les républicains existent et plus il
manquerait cruellement à l'équilibre
démocratique de notre pays ça veut dire
que nous aurions un grand centre et des
extrêmes et puis point la ligne ça veut
dire que l'alternance ne serait possible
qu'avec les extrêmes ça veut dire que
disparaîtrait une grande famille de
pensées ni du gaullisme et qui a devant
elle j'en suis persuadée et j'espère
vous en avoir donné la démonstration
dans tous les sujets que j'ai abordés et
que vous avez abordé ce soir la
démonstration que et bien cette famille
politique est là une autre voix apportée
que celle de la majorité présidentielle
et naturellement que celle de la nuque
et que celle du rassemblement national
dont l'obsession est notre mort donc
voilà je pense que sur tous les sujets
notre famille politique notre famille de
pensée c'est
un état
la restauration de l'autorité
l'autorité sous toutes ses formes
l'autorité à l'école l'autorité dans la
rue l'autorité à nos frontières
c'est la solidarité parce que c'est
inscrit dans nos gènes Gaulistes nous
nous sommes pas
pour l'extinction de toute forme de
solidarité et il est utile et chacun
d'entre nous peut en avoir besoin la
jeune mère de famille comme
l'enfant d'un parent âgé comme celui qui
va connaître le chômage voilà la
solidarité elle est indispensable mais
une solidarité bien comprise qui ne
ruine pas les finances publiques qui
n'encourage pas
et bien le
[Musique]
le recours à
des stratagèmes qui utilisent la
solidarité nationale pour pour ne pas
travailler ou pour se dérober aux règles
communes ou bien commun et parfois à la
loi et puis c'est aussi l'importance que
nous accordons à la liberté la liberté
notamment dans le travail qui n'est pas
le libéralisme débridé
c'est aussi considérer que la France
n'est pas seulement la France de la
capitale et des métropoles c'est aussi
la France de la capitale et des
métropoles dont nous sommes
malheureusement trop absents et qu'il
nous faudra reconquérir mais c'est aussi
l'équité territoriale en faveur de la
ruralité donc être républicain c'est
tout ça et si cette voie là nous ne la
portons plus qui la portera pour vous
pas pour nous pas pour notre petite
famille politique
qui a une grande histoire et qui aspire
à revenir aux responsabilités mais pour
vous pour les Français tout simplement
et pour le bienfait de la France c'est
pour ça que nous voulons continuer à
porter cette voie avec vous j'espère
vous en avoir convaincu la campagne
d'adhésion est ouverte si vous voulez
choisir votre président mais il faudra
que vous soyez à jour de cotisation
pardon d'être un peu de revenir à des
réalités un peu basiques mais voilà
venez au républicains vous y avez toute
votre place et votre voix sera entendue